man i could start a whole new channel on
on like
the
artards of reddit right that's that's
pretty much what i could call it
um this post here dude says girlfriend
keeps talking to guys when i'm not
around he's 27 she's 26 they've been
together for almost nine years now we
have always had a strong relationship we
can always talk things out recently she
has come she's been going out with her
girlfriends when she comes home she
talks about the people they meet as of
late
these have only been guys
so what's your take on
you know letting the girl go out to hang
out with her girlfriends in bars and
nightclubs fellas
mom
women with boyfriends that they're
serious about don't do it
yeah there's no reason there's no reason
to do it no she'll give you every excuse
in the book and she'll say well
i'm just going out with my girlfriends i
want to go out dancing or i want to
listen to music or whatever it is but
don't be insecure don't be controlling
she's going on the appetizer
advertising
yeah based on the age you know she's
she's hitting epiphany
and time
and close to baby rabies and she's
obviously looking to trade up she's
putting off my mind whatever party years
it sounds like she's 26 they've been
together for nine years she's now
starting to have and probably for maybe
longer than that she's having buyer's
remorse so now she's
look like i'm i'm just
still young and hot you know i'm with
this guy who probably is not the guy
that i want to be with and he's been
with me forever maybe he was the you
know athlete in high school or he was
the captain football team or fraternity
guy in college and
um
now let me just stop you there because i
want to read the rest of this too so
yeah
on the whole thing but at the end of the
day guys
uh if you're in a relationship with the
check and you've and and she's yours
like she's had the talk like where do we
stand she she's not allowed to go out
right
that's that's a trade-off i mean you
want to go out and party and get dressed
up and market yourself to other guys
then you're single
right
otherwise
you don't do that simple as that
uh it goes on to say
she's always been super outgoing and
social and i love that about her this
guy's an idiot
but lately she's been giving out her
number to these guys
[Laughter]
not only is she going out with her
girlfriends and talking other dudes
coming back home and rubbing it in his
face and saying i'm talking to the dudes
she then proceeds to tell him that she's
getting the phone numbers of these dudes
it gets better
i asked her about it when a guy kept
texting her that i didn't know
dude's texting his girlfriend and he's
like yo you know you're talking to oh
some random guy that i met at a
nightclub bar and he gave me his number
and we're just texting
she said it was a guy she met in vegas
why is your why are you permitting your
girlfriend to go down to las vegas guys
what's the matter with you seriously
you know what happens in vegas right
i've been to vegas i'm sure you've been
to vegas
you don't let your girl go anywhere
overnight like vegas or new york city or
any of those girls trips
anyway when she went to a concert sure
that's all she did just went to a
concert she talked about it and when i
asked her if she told him she was in a
relationship she said no why would that
matter after that conversation she's
been doing she's been kind of hiding her
phone from me
i've always trusted her and she's never
given a reason not to dude have you been
sleepwalking through like the last nine
years this is see this is what guys like
johnny depp do is they ignore red flags
because she touches his pee pee
and then they just like you know carry
on through until it's too late i don't
know if you know johnny depp was drunk
or stoned or he just didn't care what
his problem was but you don't get to
turds on your bed by accident that's not
like her first red flag she's done a lot
of other things prior to that
am i just in my head or should i ask her
about it is what this dude is saying
i don't know guys moff what do you got i
know you're
i know the engine's running on this one
what do you got yeah there's a lot to
unpack here i mean so so i think look
it's a nine-year relationship
um
this is just pure guessing and
speculation but
uh maybe this guy was like i said
high school sweethearts captain football
team or he was president of fraternity
in college in that environment she saw
him as like the alpha guy the best that
she could do
and now maybe he is like graduating he
doesn't have a sense of purpose he's
maybe a lowly person or maybe he's lower
he doesn't have any standards is one
problem like like he has absolutely no
standards and he has no frame in this
relationship whatsoever she's doing what
she wants when she wants yeah it's zero
and he's got this ideal
he's like oh we have a very strong
relationship we can always talk things
out it's like okay well that's what you
think right i bet if you found your
instagram you'd probably find pictures
of your butthole on there too
yeah i'm sure it's a disaster so you
know it's just she's now realizing that
she's wasted essentially her prime years
on this guy who she doesn't see as her
best option anymore now she's
capitalizing she wants to get back to
her party years and she's saying hey
i've got four or five more years and she
understands the clock is ticking i hung
out with you i did the thing i wanted to
you know i was loyal to you and now i
want to have my fun while i still have
some some prime years left so yeah very
common very typical i'm not surprised at
all by this but uh and also it sounds
like she's doing things it's almost like
she's poking the bear like she's
doing things so outwardly
that
she's almost goading him into dumping
her or breaking up with her so she can
not only chase new dick guilt-free
but also still be able to play the
victim of somebody that got dumped in
the relationship so that's something
that i've found it's you know somebody
told me one time it's like yeah girls
don't dump guys they push them to the
edge where actually he dumps her first
um irishman you're you're a little bit
more of a seasoned gentleman you're
closer to my age what's your take on all
of this
my take is that
the guy had to write this and post it
and read it and re-read it and he was
able to put all that down on paper and
ask people it's like his house is on
fire and he has to go and post it and
say well guys there's smoking flame all
around my house and it's 200 000 degrees
in here is my house on fire the guy
knows exactly and this is how blue pill
he is he had to go and ask other guys if
what he's telling everyone in this pause
that he's actually seen is true
to me it's just absolutely amazing you
know what i should have
i should have dug up the um
original post
and just like taking a look at
some of the responses girlfriend keeps
telling guys when i'm not
keeps talking to god talking talking to
guys that i'm not around okay let's see
what we get
um
we got to get you like a uh image of
colin uh farrell or something for your
uh
but i'm just saying like
you wrote this down you wrote all these
facts down reviewed it you posted it to
read it and you didn't see anything in
that post it's a dumpster fire dude and
this is how blue pill guys have become
that you know they become so attached to
the one that they're literally you know
she could be standing over a dead body
with a knife and blood dripping from the
guy like poster hey do you think my
girlfriend has murdered someone there
was a dead body at her feet and they had
there was a knife in her hand and it was
dripping
it's not that obvious dude i just
you know what there's i i googled the
exact title and a totally different one
came up like it just goes to show you
how common this is out there that these
nerds are like like this one's i'm 22
girlfriend's 20 and she chats with other
guys we did we we did get a relationship
after
sorry after over half a year of dating
at the start of the relationship i saw
her phone and she talked to many other
guys on whatsapp yeah of course you know
women's women are never really single
right like they're always talking to
somebody apparently even in
relationships with dudes i read our
conversations and some were flirtatious
of course
uh when i told her this uh she sort of
denied the flirting but did apologize
and said she would stop talking to them
i was just like
i trust her not to cheat on me yeah okay
she's flirting with other guys and he's
like i trust her not to cheat on me
she's a jolly good girl dopey dopey dope
this is what guys do complicate like we
were talking about this you know before
we went live guys complicate life
justify why right like this is just
dudes
a business thing i read earlier and it
says um people buy on impulse and then
they justify what logic later they
reason it out later and that's what that
guy is doing he knows exactly what's
going on but he's he's looking for he's
grasping at straws and he's going you
know it's done it's over bro
we need we need more people to call
these guys
idiots
but i think that just a little bit of
bullying can be good
you know like when you got bullied and
they called you too slow on the track
team you would try to run as fast as you
could and if you had to lose some weight
or train a little bit more you would do
that right like a little bit of bullying
is good like let's let's just bring some
back guys you know
well language is powerful right i mean i
think i might have taken this from paul
but i remember you know something that
either he told me i came here who it was
but it's like
instead of saying hey man like yeah
she's probably like seeing other guys
you need to say hey man no she's blowing
other dudes and writing other dick
because one is like very soft and one is
like
the other is just jarring to your psyche
as a man where it's like holy and now
you have that image in your head and
that you have that pain and now you have
that hopefully what drives you to get
off your ass and do something about it
but you know you have to take it to a
certain level where you're going to be
able you're you're going to feel that
pain by seeing that imagery like it's
the only way that works yeah i mean you
automatically get called a a problem
dude if you start having conversations
like that though that's just how they
returned to you what's up jared how you
doing man
i am doing well how are you guys all
doing doing pretty good man yeah i'm
just getting settled in i was actually
in new york with mother's weekend so
trying to get over that jet lag whatever
tiredness that lingers after that for
those sorts of trips yeah and
moff is just in vegas too so he knows
what happens down there right um i just
want to go through some of these
responses here to this uh girlfriend
keeps talking to dudes so
i said what would your advice be to this
fool like i just wanted to see what the
internet was going to tell us today
so let's see what godly advice we got
you're showing to your girlfriend that
you're being insecure with your
relationship and this gives her more
power than you shitty advice she's
moving on they've had teenagers and
they've been going and been going
together for nine years it's too long
for boyfriend girlfriend perhaps she
wanted to get married and he didn't want
to we don't know shut up you simp this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
you should just go ahead and buy condoms
for her next girls trip hopeless this
guy understands
oh man
these are all too funny anyway you can
go have a look at those on the feed hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you